there are no FDA approved treatments or
vaccines for the corona virus pandemic
currently but drug makers are scrambling
to fix that I don't think we've seen
anything like this as far as several
dozen drug makers rushing to the call to
develop different therapeutics against
this virus so there are three main
efforts I'm watching for these near-term
repurposed drugs one is called REM D
severe REM desapear was previously
tested as Anna bola treatment it's being
tested in patients who have already been
infected and have moderate or severe
cases of Kovan 19 is a broad-spectrum
antiviral meaning it's not targeted at
one specific function but sort of has an
activity that could be applicable
against a range of viruses there's an
HIV drug called Calera that's being
tested in some clinical trials and a B
the drug maker behind that has donated
that in quantity to China for that
testing chloroquine is an old generic
anti-malaria drug this drug was first
approved in 1949 by the US so there's a
long safety profile where we understand
the toxicity and how to take the drug
it's very unclear at this point if it'll
work in coronavirus there's been a lot
of anecdotal reports of success in some
countries including China South Korea
and even Belgium have put chloroquine
directly in their treatment guidelines
for coronavirus so in the medium-term
we're watching companies like Eli Lilly
Regeneron and fur biotechnology they're
all developing monoclonal antibodies
which are essentially drugs that would
fight the virus and there's a potential
that they can be used prophylactically
which means when you look at a high-risk
patient population healthcare workers
family members of kovat 19 patients
those could be the targeted groups for a
prophylactic antibody which would
essentially protect that person from
being infected this is very early
research none of these are in clinical
testing yet they're still being
developed in laboratories but the speed
of this pandemic has forced drug makers
to act as quickly as possible in the
long term vaccines are the gold standard
of drug development with infectious
diseases vaccines can prevent
affections before they even occur on
like the short-term or medium-term
treatments which would generally treat
patients who already have severe or
moderate cases of kovat 19 that also
requires much longer testing to make
sure a vaccine is safe and effective you
don't want to give a treatment to
hundreds of millions of people that
might make them worse or not work
against the virus so this requires
extensive clinical testing but the drug
industry is also moving extremely
rapidly at developing these vaccines the
first clinical trial the vaccine has
already started the first patients have
already received doses of an
experimental vaccine against the corona
virus so while that trial has just begun
it's a long road it's kind of the first
mile in a marathon for vaccine
development top US health officials have
estimated that timeline at 12 to 18
months to determine if a vaccine is safe
and effective against this virus the
questions that remain are about price
and access who would get it first and
what would the price be